Let's get to the phones at (617) 830-4750
and see what is on people's minds today.
Uh, why don't we start with our color from
the six seven eight area code?
Who's calling today from six seven eight.
Hi David, this is Joseph.
Hey Joseph.
What's going on?
Hey, uh, crazy that I'm on the show right
now.
This is cool.
Yeah.
So my question is, is about the two 87 g program.
Do you know anything about that?
I know nothing about it.
What is it?
Okay.
Well, it's a, basically a program about, um,
partnering between ice and local sheriffs.
And I was just, well, since you don't know
anything about it, but it's something I wanted
to ask you.
Oh, is this, so maybe I know, maybe I know
about it, but not by that name.
Is this the idea that ice wants local sheriffs
to be reporting to them on immigration status
of people that they're interacting with?
Yes, exactly.
So what happens with program is, uh, ice basically
deputizes the sheriff's department to be ice
officials and acts as ice officials and they
get extra funding because of, so I was just
wondering about, like, is there any way that
a state legislator could like fight against
that in any way with any kind of legislation?
I don't know.
Since it's federal funding, like, um, yeah,
I don't know the legality of it because, so
sheriffs are usually county based.
Um, and it's unclear to me whether those are
decisions that the state could, could estate,
outlaw any county making the decision to accept
those funds.
What happens in terms of the federal supremacy?
I, I genuinely have no idea what the legality
of it is.
I know that I'm against it, but I wouldn't
be able to say what the legality of, of a
ban at the state level on accepting those
funds and partnering in that way would be.
Yeah, that was just my question because I
live in Gwinnett County and we actually deport
20% of the immigrants in this small area.
So that's just a big issue that I was thinking
about it.
Maybe like do a video about it or something.
That'd be super awesome.
Uh, just, I honestly don't know.
I've been researching and myself, I'd volunteer
at the local Gwinnette Democratic Party.
So it's just something I wanted to talk to
you about.
Yeah.
Well, you know, the thing is, Joseph, even
if there are funds available, it's still time
that your local sheriff's department is spending
on something that to you might just not be
a valuable use of time.
And that is a huge area where people should
be activating around.
I mean, if you live in a place and you presumably
have a, you do have an interest in how the
sheriff's department is spending their time,
you should have a voice which says, I don't
want sheriffs wasting time communicating with
ice about the immigration status of people.
I want them focused on whatever it might be.
If there's opioid abuse issues going on where
you live or whatever else the case may be,
um, that, that cert.
So I think that you should be activating around
it and you're doing the right thing by thinking
about this stuff.
Yeah.
Oh, that's really great.
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to do.
I actually was speaking to a recent candidate,
um, that's on the democratic side for our
Gwinette sheriff and he was talking about
ending two 87 g program.
Yeah.
And um, I just was trying to think if there's
any other way, if I could just try and engage
with my state reps or things like that,
I would do it.
And I'll listen even though I don't know what
the legal circumstances are, contact them
anyway and they can tell you what it is.
Make, make them work and tell you what it
is.
All right.
Joseph, thank you for the call.
I really appreciate it.
Topic and glad, uh, glad that you brought
it up to me.
Hope to hear from you again.